is it weird you know we're talking about
you've been doing this yet you said like
23 years like that's not normal for you
know you to be around all these actors
from the beginning and then have that
family it's like a whole separate family
yeah what's that like if you've grown up
in the show Honey yeah it literally is
is very similar to like uh you know a TV
show we've seen each other grow up yeah
on the Godmother two couple of Vince
kids like you know we've we've seen you
know we've had people leave us
uh we just grew up together and yeah it
is a family and it's insane that we've
lasted this long without you know biting
each other's heads off I don't know like
another franchise has really done that
in that sense you know what I'm saying
like even with like stars that skipped
years and years and years you know yeah
it's different I don't know if I know a
franchise that's done it like that
that's incredible now with the original
cast I think we did kind of make history
that way and me and and uh I think Dom
and Letty have the longest standing
relationship uh on in a feature film wow
yeah 23 years lasts longer than most
real people yeah I know I can't even
last two years with a partner man I need
some of that I am great on film I know
I'm great on film apparently
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going